do rassemblement de lieux différents
mais une seule et même cible retraités
et personnels d pad dénonce la politique
du gouvernement
mouvement principal celui des maisons de
retraite partout en france et dans les
yvelines
le mouvement est inédit pour le secteur
à l'appel de l'ensemble des syndicats et
des directeurs d'établissement pour
réclamer notamment une hausse des
effectifs
le problème c'est qu'on ne réussit même
pas à respecter le rythme des résidents
et surtout à respecter leur autonomie ce
qui fait qu'on fait des fois des choses
à leur place parce qu'on peut pas les on
peut pas prendre le temps pour les aider
on ressent bien les familles ce qu'elles
disent se fait vite il ya aussi les
toilettes les bains qui sont peut-être
pas donner forcément
régulièrement elles voudront donner
beaucoup plus est ne peuvent comme des
douches face à une dégradation quand
même au niveau de la prise en charge de
la personne âgée
plus tôt dans la journée ce sont les
retraités qui se sont réunis devant la
préfecture à versailles hausse de la csg
gel des pensions baisse des apl la
colère et variés contre le gouvernement
et pour la défense du porte monnaie au
pouvoir d'achat diminue d'année en année
depuis au moins ses parents fin 2-2 plus
que moi j'ai pris ma retraite je sais
que mon pouvoir d'achat a diminué
donc je trouve que c'est pas juste et
que c'est toujours la même chose que les
actionnaires s'enrichissent emmanuel
macron président des riches l'argument
social est désormais rodée et pourrait
être encore développé jeudi avec une
nouvelle manifestation prévue
cette fois ci contre la réforme du bac
et la nouvelle plateforme parcours sup